know who are gonna diet thank God her
guys guys come on was so funny it isn't
us
it's really freaking dark isn't it like
really [ __ ] dark what do you pay
maybe it doesn't let her pay they like
did we forget to actually sign out to
pay the elective
it's the whole street Oh what about you
now guys I can't just say here in the
dark shut my phone died
[ __ ] my [ __ ] died to mindin but I'm
at 12% and we might need it in case of
emergencies so the ice powerup stops the
porn that has the ice hookin from being
moved for any reason well come on guys
this is gonna be fun
and once she made her way into the
bathroom that's when she turned on the
light and found her husband okay have
you ever been in love yeah I was very
much in love my ex-boyfriend you might
have right jack oh yeah he was at that
party yeah he looked like a dick yeah
it's actually a really nice guy we're
just very different thank you oh you
truth or dare
uh truth have you ever taken a shower
Wow
yeah I'm to one this morning with your
mother
Hey Oh Cheryl was very kind and gentle
and love to get scrubbing hey Bridget
your turn um yeah I of course you picked
their pick true
I went there we don't know anything
about your life you know me
what about England what was your life in
England like not much to tell really
it's fine she pick Derek you know what's
- of course I'm sorry okay Dara
what's our dare uh I suppose it out I'm
sorry oh oh yeah your turn let's go ah
dare you to kiss that's your idea
friends like each other like that
okay then whenever you guys kissed
alright no maybe we should have you two
kiss first though
that's like that seems oh my god this is
so stupid
she's got this over there you go okay
I'm gonna go get the wine from my room
oh that was something I didn't want to
see and that's bad so I will be getting
wine Olson okay maybe you should cool it
on the whiskey what what is that okay
hi oh we're hugging aha you were so
sweet to me
here's do you found out yes
we sure yeah
no cuddles just the best yeah it's just
hard you were the one who said you
didn't want this yeah you know we live
together now so we can't I mean we could
that is an awful idea
yeah okay we should go back up
whoo what's going on here
I am I I don't know she was cold and I
she did this I didn't do it oh okay okay
yeah I'm gonna go bad I like that too